mir hossein qu'on ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle c'est bien même johnny rotten
pourtant c'est un pote tu vois bas prix
tu vois ma fille m'aime je lis rothen ne
bouge pas dans le giga quand la
révolution bien d'ailleurs
la ja vichy jeu saw j'ai vu quelques
e-mails une fille qui s'appelle pâte
lamberti qui me dit sa révolution en
coûte cher à bafiba oui il est toujours
pas là fred béquille donc de faire son
site sur les gens qui veulent bouger
débat fist puis à quelques opposants il
ya un mec s'appelle vincent vallières
qui a viré sa fiancée clair parce
qu'elle bougeait par le jingle se fout
mais qu'il vient d'un revendeur et il y
en a d'autres comme mourad abbas qui dit
moi je bouge pas pendant une gueule
parce que toute façon je suis bien au
chaud sous ma couette et alors ouais il
ya une fille qui dit s'appelle floriane
elle dit si j'enlève un vêtement à
chaque jingle est-ce que je peux bouger
la réponse est oui dérogation spéciale
alors on va faire avec jenny rothen une
interview anti portrait chinois
daniel difficile à expliquer le portrait
chinois c'est si vous étiez une fleur
qu'est ce que vous seriez comme fleurs
je serai un mieux autisme lentilles
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
maladie donc johnny rotten if you were
10 is what kind of disease good to be ce
serait la peste parce que je ressemble à
un rap par la peste
si vous étiez une injure suite une
injure ouais ça veut dire daniel ne sais
pas le traducteur espèce de brigands
bagnole je ferai du porno très bien
daniel
bine bine peut-être plus rapidement si
vous étiez un accident l'ambulance si
vous étiez une guerre troisième gardien
si vous étiez un vis à vis si vous étiez
un supplice je pense que d'une certaine
manière musicalement je le suis c'est
bien si vous étiez une cicatrice score
cicatrices anales
un poison eisel sa oman à la salmonelle
j'aime bien les salmonelles fumée si
vous étiez un [ __ ] beaucoup dirais que
je suis déjà si vous étiez un assassin
n'y aurait pas de problème de gestion je
pense vous étiez un virus quelque chose
sur internet
l avion à l'avenir j'aime aussi la
touche
si vous étiez un dictateur à jeudi lui
je crois est d'une certaine manière
bizarre un dictateur espagnol nous parce
que ça devient pire 17h02 mouche
espagnol boutique espagnole
si vous étiez un terroriste mais je le
suis avec a demandé à la famille royale
britannique ils me connaissent très bien
et si vous étiez la mort quel genre de
mort seriez-vous deux roues ça c'est
quelque chose que je n'entends pas je
suis sourd tout d'un coup bravo
j'aime me lancer